hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Taylor
Bradley Taylor and I today are gonna
check out a baby were filming bless you
you didn't even try to cover that up you
don't want to try to cover up a sneeze
that could hurt so Netflix they have
brought us daredevil from Marvel and now
they're bringing us Jessica Jones you
know that I I'm not as familiar with the
female Marvel characters cuz I'm sexist
apparently yeah that's what he was
Christ Jesus Christ was not as sexist
jeezum crow he was a sexist I don't know
much about Jessica Jones I think this is
like the first real superhero I know
they got agent Carter out there but this
is like a superhero one who flies and
has super strength and stuff so the
basic all the basic power yeah yeah and
Netflix's daredevil which I [ __ ] love
one of my all-time favorite shows what I
loved about daredevil was you really
didn't have to be in touch with a Marvel
Universe to get it yeah I'm hoping this
show kind of does the same but at the
same time this character is linked to a
lot of Marvel characters yeah to Peter
Parker it's linked to Tony Stark it's
linked to a lot of [ __ ] people so
maybe this could be the ultimate
connection at the same time because just
contradicting myself let's do this a big
part of the job is looking for the worst
two people ouch turns out I excel at
that Europe I I'm just trying to make a
living you know boost cost money usually
just Jones [ __ ]
I saw you what do you want to go can you
touch the wall
stop moving call nice that's level think
I'm way I see you being here I'll just
put a target on your back yeah been
there done this song what if there was
someone else out there but his ability
was to make people do whatever he wanted
you like more control you have no idea
what he made me do
Justin isn't here now he always always
here
yes you'd like to invite me in
absolutely so I seduced kilgrave leaves
a trail of broken people behind him you
made me jump for hours as high as I
could he said I was never as good as you
he's back he's coming for me let's stop
now
Jessica I'm the only one who matches you
and we're an active on Jesus God didn't
do this the devil did
this stone up by the hair of me the
stone away whoa that looks pretty cool
looks [ __ ] menacing I really like her
yeah she's I think really good for this
part okay you can feel this nipple chill
she's the back of the hand baby not the
front don't worry that's how intense
this is that's how was it there were a
couple times when I actually jumped
during that yeah that's hard like when
they had the guns and then they stepped
off the thing and they were all swinging
that was really creepy and eerie what I
love about what marbles do in Netflix is
they're really providing something that
we have not seen before from them along
the lines with daredevil this is a much
darker Marvel tale yeah and it seems
like it's gonna be violent too and it's
just cool to see a badass like female
heroine yeah in this in this in like
this Marvel Universe so I hope gets
included in the movies as well
I remember her in Breaking Bad oh yeah
yeah she was great in that like I love
her personality she was like you know
she was only in a few episodes but she
was such an impactful character that
lasted till the very last episode she
has a lot of weight as an actress like
just her presence on stage like or on
the screen you want to watch her like
she's very captivating to watch and she
can convey a lot I think just with very
small facial adjustments you know my
favorite kind of characters are the ones
who bring full life to a role you know
like this could have easily been like
OneNote badass talking chick right but
there's like a full personality to her
like you get the vulnerable side but
it's also you get a really tough side
it's a different kind of female hero
performance that I haven't seen yet I
kind of liked that she's driven it seems
like by fear mostly it seems like she's
a little bit paranoid but she's not
overly paranoid she's not you know
crumbling under not the weight of it but
it seems like she always feels like
she's being followed and I think that
that's a really interesting concept for
for a superhero absolutely I love how
there's this pass that she has that she
wasn't in control of but she
horrible things that are haunting her to
this day which make her afraid to use
her powers yeah that's an interesting
backstory to give to a character rather
than like here's the origin tale of them
they're like worse we're starting her
off where she already has the powers and
stuff and he or she is and would this
past it's like really [ __ ] up right
and the villain seems I'm really
intrigued I wish I knew more about
horrible than saving a villain II have
no idea who I'm sure there's plenty of
people think about my boxes are like
goats this person who Gideon I'm
intrigued by how they're portraying the
villain there are some great shots in
there like the police station where
they're all still and he seems like mind
control I've always said if there was
one superpower I would get some people
like fly be invincible or something I
would be able to control minds because
you can manipulate anyone into what you
want to do oh jeez that's one of the
scariest things though I feel like
that's one of the darkest darkest
timeline read people's minds and you can
get what you want
oh look I'm already really good at
manipulating people I'm really good okay
I'm sure everything I get so many chicks
on this channel could you ask them to
come on the channel and they're like
yeah sure yeah it's not really
manipulation now it's more like I become
friends and then they come on it's not
ya know I don't really know how to
manipulate I didn't I didn't think so
I would say I manipulated Veronica and
abeba truth is she manipulated me I can
see that but I feel like it's a dark
superpower though is my manipulation
yeah is it dark suit it's like you know
when you in Avatar the blood bending I
feel like it's that same idea it's like
it's a burden as well as as a power she
also comes from Veronica Mars and there
is like an investigation vibe to this
kind of move this kind of show actually
ya know it's like there that she's like
the detective in a way who you know
doesn't get paid for the job so but
she's doing her thing she's doing it
because she wants to absolutely because
she feels the necessity to I know Mike
Colter is playing Luke Cage which is a
huge deal we wanted Luke Cage in the
story for a long time I don't know much
about Luke Cage yeah I don't people
think I know a lot about comic books but
really I only I know a lot about Batman
and that's about as far as well we got a
little Batman that me is my favorite I
love that don't don't upset too many
Marvel fans right now stop it stop it
you're gonna upset them this is it
Batman's awesome but not nearly as good
as the
stop talking about them and you're gonna
get us in a lot of trouble okay stop
saying it honestly my one problem with
the trailer is I found myself more
intrigued by the villain who I think is
named purple man yeah who doesn't look
purple at all the villain I feel more
intrigued by who the villain is more
Jessica Jones I don't know if I feel
more intrigued I think I think I feel
equally intrigued and I feel like
villains kind of have the freedom to be
more intriguing in a way because they
can have more mystery to them they could
be more menacing they can be more
menacing we didn't have to find out a
ton about him to want to know more about
him I think if she was more in the
shadows we might have found her more
interesting but because um be invested
in her it's a cool story for the first
season of redemption - yeah because
she's trying to right her wrongs from
the past as well and I like seeing tales
of that of like retribution and stuff
like that you know and in the trailer
they show that Luke Cage and Jessica
Jones they they started her like having
sex at one point oh yeah yeah yeah I
figured that was gonna happen when she
was like I usually have to pay for my
drinks out like Oh interracial sex yeah
one of the best categories on many sites
out there I'm sure yeah oh God it's
nothing better than watching like a huge
okay all right going to it any white
woman anyway guys thanks for tuning into
the channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe today and become a reject a
hero nope reject hero and check out
Taylor Bradley's channel where you can
get Bradley Duff on the Taylor Bradley
channel where she's launching a web
series and she already started filming
it that are imposed for a couple
episodes right now so check it out
subscribe now so you can be alerted when
it's out
Alex Lopez hey Ryan I've been watching
the channel for about two months now and
I watched a lot of your videos you guys
are absolutely hilarious PS you should
start doing gameplays I think it will
help add diversity to your channel but
with her way you guys you mean
either either either yeah you guys are
awesome thanks Alex Lopez dude you're
the one who's awesome I want to see what
you look like no subscribers look like
serial killers and so do you my friend I
get like a serial killer /dp vibe from
this guy I could see that he seems a
little like modern emo with the hair
swoop yeah yeah but yeah I date the
shirt it's kind of a nice shirt oh yeah
it's like all serial killers are kind of
emo in a way yeah I guess that's true
he's a student driver there he's a
student driver okay you look a little
Asian spanic yeah Asian Hispanic his
fame even I'm trying to combine don't
hurt yourself if I was you I've a girl
my hair it even more but I will match it
to your pubes man bun I would put a man
bun a bunch of hair just like a whole
bunch of hair where you can't even see
it when you get erect it pops out that's
the most disgusting thing I've ever
heard
don't do that what you want to do is
learn how to get an erection by just
popping out not grow okay okay we're
good we're good pop cut